men like people do that as well because
there's lots of generalization going on
here and I think
people do that if you've had something
in the past some people carry from their
past relationship this person did this
to me so they see that signing you they
assume but I think we need to be a bit
more open with
trauma everyone's got things every
everything
you're giving excuses for what you did
there's no reason why if you meet me I
need to start being open to your trauma
no one asks you to do it no wait hold on
wait hold on no one asked you to deal
with guys that are going to give you
trauma now you expect me to be a to be
some type of therapist I'm the man
that's not my job as a to be a therapist
to fix guys that you shouldn't have got
with in the first place I think it's
quite you're putting things on to men
that men don't actually need to deal
with I'm just supposed to be a good man
that I don't need to be your therapist
and to fix why you why this guy did this
to you and did that well I mean you're
sounding like somebody that's
experienced some really toxic women
because that's no because seriously
because it's coming it's coming across
that way because
I'm gonna live just come and sat here if
you know I tried to catch him what the
subject was but there's a bear
aggression in where you in the way he's
not aggressive he's just being honest
and what he's saying what he's saying is
that like why should the men of the
future have to pay for your past so if
you if you had and I'm not saying you
did I know not all girls did but this is
just a common thing that men tell me and
like if you had toxic boyfriend toxic X
bad boy bad boy bad boy and then you get
in this new relationship and you dump
all of that onto the new guy why does he
have to deal with that yeah no one
should have to deal with that however
you come with your own things as well
everyone comes with their own things I
feel like it's about how people unpack
it I think once you you know what those
things are it's not to go to the new
person that you're seeing oh this has
happened to me and you better not do
this to me that's what I mean it's about
everybody has their things so my thing
is this right it gets to me when women
automatically when a man speaks you
start trying to put all this aggression
all these types of things it's no it's
not that please we need to stop this
because it's it's a it's a tactic that
women use all the time especially on his
it's a shame and shame and tactic as
soon as a man speaks about something you
start talking about aggression and all
these types of things we need to really
to stop it because that's not what's
going on here but I have to I have to
pull it up because I always say listen
to people's words yeah listen to my
words don't listen to the tone because
what tends to happen is you use the tone
and you used to use the tone to to take
away from the actual message the actual
point so um yeah like there's no
aggression here there's no animosity
there's nothing but literally what I'm
saying is women tend to go and do this
and we have experienced this and as men
were trying to speak and tell you about
experiences and we speak in a way that
men speak whenever we we do was shame
for it
that's a natural response for you right
I think it's important you know when
you're talking about women that get run
through by Bad Boys and whatnot what not
I think it's important to remember that
there are women that choose those people
like I have a ex-friend and that was her
thing like she wants the hood boy she
wants the gangster she wants the trapper
and then there's women that never see
that part of them and fall in
like
get become attracted to like the
sensitivity that they may see in a man
but then he turns out to be he's
controller yeah
women know we know we know deep down
like I just don't buy it when girls say
oh I was Bamboozled one day no you work
come on let me ask you when you said
since it does does do sensitive guys
attract
um women
do sensitive men attract women generally
yeah one one day me and you might
actually sit down with my ex I ended in
court with
yeah wow yeah super super super abusive
it was horrible and he turned out to be
a lovely guy now with friends but your
friends
yes I am because yeah I'm a quality
woman who overstands like the trauma
that people have been through and
understand why certain things happen and
help them to progress and stop
perpetuate a negative Cycles but anyway
he I I fell for him based on a fight
that happened on a bus and his care to
the little boy and the old man that were
like caught up in it is what made me
look back and then start a conversation
with him right I had no idea he was a
bad boy he was a super like chubby Asian
boy like like nerdy looking whatever
whatever and it was after months of
really like sweet conversations and
whatnot what not there was no inkling
there was no red flag that this could be
a bad guy
green flags yeah that would show me that
he's a lover which is very common in
abusive men so don't you think so
someone who's too emotional yeah is more
likely to be an abuser yeah and that's
something that I now identify after the
years because they don't know how to
control their emotions so I think it's
really important that we don't kind of
oh you knew because
it's not it's not hard so so it was
about six months you said before he
started to show signs uh the first like
proper proper abuse was after like nine
months after nine months and then how
long did it go on for that for three
years for three years and then you took
him to court no uh police officer drove
past as he punched me into a bush uh
undercover police officer drove past
they jumped out and took him they didn't
need me because they witnessed it um so
so but this is where I don't understand
you say you didn't know but you were he
wasn't abusive for nine months and then
you knew for three and you I was a child
and that's why I've been through so much
therapy to make sure that I don't how
old were you I was I was that's not
because I can't no no like let's not
yeah because if because the reason why
you said you was a child so we need to
know how old I'm saying it would win so
when someone says what stage you stayed
yeah I didn't know I didn't we're not
doing that but the the point is that
doesn't sound honest because you did
know if you stayed longer you stayed for
three years you were there I I knew I'm
saying how I became his girlfriend
before me becoming his girlfriend the
courting the initial period there were
no signs it was after I was his
girlfriend I was his then every he was
relaxed do you understand I was with no
I'm just I was with you yeah until you
until you said oh I was young and I
asked you how old you was and you won't
tell me see that's that's how
disingenuous to me because the rest of
the because like I said to Sarah I would
love if we could not have a comment we
don't have to we're just in the end no
this came about from me suggesting uh uh
talk with him present do you understand
so all the disenges so do you think that
as an abuser as you're saying that he is
he would say
yes I wanna I was an abuser and this is
why
I don't think
yeah obviously I'd have to ask it but
I'm just saying because you're saying
you want to sit down and like yeah I
think it would be an interesting and
important but because when I hear people
speak in a certain way I think it can be
quite dangerous because think of all the
women
think of all the women or men that might
be in a situation or whatever and when
you feel like your chastise oh you knew
deal with it like no that's not the case
there are people we didn't say I didn't
say deal with that I know you did it
sorry I shouldn't have added that in
there but for someone that has you know
been in a situation where they have
just dealt with it when someone says oh
you knew you knew you should I mean oh
but you stayed for three years I think
it's important do you see how that looks
to to the outside like if we look at you
and say like for instance if I'm coming
home for three years and someone's as
soon as I walk in the door someone's
punching me in my face there's lots of
things about that yeah but I'm just
saying I was I was I was
um living by myself I had got a state uh
like squatting I'd done like living in a
foster home like I was I was not in
touch with my immediate family at that
point
there's a lot yeah there's a lot to
consider for you to be able to
understand that I don't really think
it's appropriate to unpack here and now
but if we use our um if we think a
little bit you know so so I don't think
it's fair to start something and then
and then not give us the full story and
then when we tried to speak about it he
said it's not fair to unpack it so what
I would say is this end of the day is
you still pick that guy you chose to be
with that guy for three years no matter
what or wherever wherever it was used to
chose to make a decision do you have any
brothers yes did you tell your brothers
no so okay once again so you had men in
your family that could have dealt with
this scenario but you chose not to go
and do it hold on wait hold on a second
hold on a second hold on a second
because I got three sisters yeah and my
sisters would know any type of man that
disrespects them that I would get the
call you chose not to call your brothers
you chose to put yourself in something
for three years and then now when you
come on here you also said you was young
I asked you how old you was you don't
want to learn you don't need to okay but
that lets me know you wasn't that's not
the problem
no because that lets me know you wasn't
young and using it as a copper bro I
just said it would invite him no but no
so so we don't so I don't know I'm sorry
sorry I think you need to remember there
was a um I was prompted to mention
something that was helping me to make
Clarity on another Point you're now like
going in this spiral Rabbit Hole I'm not
I'm just I'm just trying to sorry babe
sorry okay it's not don't don't think
I'm you know I'm high I'm willing to
talk to you like you're not because I
just ask you how was yours I've signed a
contract where sir it's not edited so
I'm saying respectfully I don't mind
sitting off camera with you like I began
the story with I would sit down with
Sarah and speak openly I really don't
appreciate like the point
but the point he's making is like I
wouldn't say I was young and then get
mad when someone said how young I didn't
get mad
I'm saying like that that's the point
because I don't know the ad I can't I've
got really really bad PTSD
um years and stuff if I go to the doctor
and they ask me what what year was this
operation what not I can't give the
exact year if I'm on camera now and I
say it was 2000 and whatever and then
it's not I don't you understand it's not
that there's any disingenuous if you
want me to Emily I hear you but it's
like but even when you say this it's
like you don't remember what yeah it's
just like it's just you brought up the
story I didn't make you bring it up and
then so and so I'm saying it's just it
gets confusing when you you bring up a
story and then we ask questions and
you're like oh no I can't you know no
I'm just telling you how it comes across
I don't know you because I know my
reasons for not wanting to say the year
I will Instagram him now and ask what
year did I get with you okay like if I
understand what so you're going to do
that what's so proud
so you forget for three years did you so
did you celebrate any birthdays together
you must remember one birthday you
celebrated so just whatever whatever
birthday you celebrate that's how old
you was count back then that's it so I'm
not asking you how the only reason why
I'm saying it is because a lot of times
women come up here and say I'm young
this happens the whole Point's been
missed no no no no no I don't even
remember why this cake like okay
basically sharing stuff Emily Emily
Emily what I'm trying to say is yeah a
lot of times people come up on here and
they say I was young and they try to use
an excuse me okay cool but then we asked
you how old you was you you negate to
tell us flying but at what point when is
when are you responsible as an adult if
you're talking 16 okay wait if you're
talking 16 we'll talk young if you're
talking 18 potentially it's before it's
like one of my first boyfriends so I so
you're talking 13. I've yeah I've
unfortunately been in 13.
one at a time guys I'm not I'm not um I
don't have anything to hide in terms of
my relationship I'm pretty open like
I've been doing podcasts about sex and
relationships and whatnot I'm open I'm
an open book you don't know me from Adam
but I'm I'm I I live in my truth the the
ugly there's a lot of ugly and I can't
even remember the point of why I even
brought up that moment of my life
because it's just been like
I feel like we've just gone down a
rabbit hole Yeah like it's weird
well with that as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible